I'm free at last
after a year in detention the German
journalist and ECHL has been released
from prison in Turkey but many others
have not been so lucky Amnesty
International's report describes a
devastating human rights situation not
just in Turkey but in many countries
around the world
is it because we are concerned to see
that individual governments are not just
blatantly flouting international and
national human rights standards but also
support an alternative approach that
builds on national unilateralism of
violation of international legal
obligations and of the notion of might
makes right when democracy Ocalan
governments are especially targeting
those who advocate freedom and human
rights while in 2016 about 280 human
rights defenders were murdered across
the world one year later the number was
over 300 in Colombia alone more than 100
people paid with their lives for their
human rights activism but there is also
a glimmer of hope in many countries more
and more civilians are defending
themselves against state repression for
example in Poland in the summer of 2017
thousands of people demonstrated against
proposed limits on the Constitutional
Court's Authority thoughts that sue
named and Entering in spite of the
increasing encroachment on the freedoms
of opinion and assembly in many
countries there are active civil society
groups and human rights defenders and
now it is important that the community
of nations and many governments support
these people these are mention winter
suits until now that has just been an
idealistic dream and the release of
Denis HL an exception in Turkey alone
more than 100 journalists remain in jail